[Music]
you talked about the incredible
opportunity to spend some time with
Harrison Ford yeah on set what sort of
things did you two talk about
I wanted to know a lot about kind of his
career trajectory I'm a driver I'm a
flyer the best takeaway was just kind of
getting his blessing on the movie in his
his vote of confidence was there like a
question that you wish you had asked I
can't think of anything in particular
I'm sure there was I mean I just wanted
you know hearing about Indiana Jones and
stuff was also like totally I was like
we were there and it was like Star Wars
but then he's also talking about Indy
and it was like right that and Blade
Runner and all these fugitives and all
these things when et sat down with the
young Han Solo star he was under the
impression it was to talk about his
upcoming movie solo a Star Wars story
until this happened how about any
specific advice or guidance specifically
to the role playing Han Solo yeah he
said if anyone asks tell them I told you
everything you need to know and then
you're not allowed to say a word he
might want to say one or two more things
oh my god that is awesome thanks for
coming by just in the neighborhood I'd
love to hear some some of your feedback
some of your reaction to watching this
young man I just thought it was
spectacular and I thought he was so
smart and how he did I just couldn't be
happier things Alden is still recovering
from the surprise that's the first day
talked to him since we had lunch I can't
describe it I'm in a state of I feel
like I'm on one of those and so where's
co-stars after we told them the news how
did you guys had a chance to meet her
he's like Superman or in Woody
Harrelson's case he actually watched
video of how it all went down did yours
oh my god that's so cool Harrison
unbelievable that's pretty cool right
[Music]